hey everyone this is ryan with ibm
excited you came by the ibm technology
channel today we're going to be talking
about what is data observability one of
the hottest topics in the data space
today but before we get there i just
want to remind you please subscribe like
the channel interact with us in the
comments this really helps us produce
the videos you want to see from us in
the future so go ahead like it share it
say it to your mom and dad you know
let's get let's get the word out there
all right so before we get into data
observability i want to tease you a
little bit
i'm going to use
a train analogy later on in this
demonstration so
what i want you to do is if you are
really excited about trains like i am i
love trains i used to play with trains
all the time during christmas time with
my grandpa growing up
this is going to be a cool example to
show you how we're connecting everything
together with data pipelines data
engineering and also observability so
we're going to get back to that i
promise
okay so let's give a little quick
history lesson of what's going on in the
industry and how we're getting to this
data observability moment that we're
seeing right now and it really comes
down to
um something going on
that is
compared to the software engineering
group and and uh
explosion that's happened in the last
you know five to eight years which is
software engineers are basically ruling
the world these developers are ruling
with frameworks and
methodologies like ci and cd
they're pioneering things like devops
they're doing things like
infra
as code all these really advanced uh
things in the software development space
it's really blown up and and these are
all like table stakes nowadays if you're
a software engineer you're basically
doing all these things and you're doing
that with building applications like
building applications in the cloud
you're building microservices
you're also building applications
so all these things are great
and
recently around five years ago there was
a blow up in the space around
observability itself there's another
video that we've done at ibm around
observability i i encourage you to check
that out and it's really around this
idea of application
performance
monitoring or
apm apm is really around being able to
detect problems and performance issues
in your application so developers can be
alerted right away and go resolve
something
whether a server was down or you had an
application a hiccup
in production you know right away
through the trace logs and issues that
they know exactly where to go to fix
that right
and that's awesome that they've got all
these tools kind of helping them out
well what's going on now is it it used
to be that you know so everywhere
everyone was a software company every
company is now a software company well
now every company is now a data company
and what's going on is that a lot of
these software engineering
folks or developers or engineers they're
actually moving to become
data engineers and so they're using a
lot of the same skill sets they're you
know code heavy
um skill sets like python and and using
frameworks like devops all these things
that we they're used to as software
engineers and now becoming data
engineers to take the same things we're
doing around continuous delivery
delivery for application development now
into
a
data development within the organization
today so
where software engineers really care
about the applications that they're
building
like cloud microservices and
applications out there what data
engineers are actually really focused on
is their data pipelines these data
pipelines are the things that are moving
the data from the source all the way to
the end state of the consumer and
they're in charge of around 80 to 90
percent
of all the data flow within their
organization today but the problem is
this is that whereas software engineers
have apm application performance
monitoring as an observability tool to
help them find things right away alert
them resolve them
data engineering really isn't there yet
and this is where observability comes
into play observability is basically
data observability is the
next step for data engineers to
operationalize any instant detection
that they have within their data
pipelines so let's walk through
and we're going to use the train analogy
as a as a pipeline so view
this train as an actual pipeline that's
going to be moving down the tracks here
but this is what data engineers will do
they are building
pipelines they're orchestrating the data
from their source data all the way to
their end consumer and these could have
hundreds to thousands of different data
pipelines that they're they're using
most commonly they're using open source
tools like apache airflow to take the
data and move it
and just to illustrate real quick this
becomes a complicated problem
because what you're doing is you're
taking
all different types of sources that you
can maybe can and cannot control
from third-party applications from
you know web server apis things like
that you're taking these things and then
we're expected to funnel them into
storage areas like a data warehouse
or something that's unstructured like a
data lake
so data engineers again they're in
charge of moving this data
to eventually
when you get the data in a in the right
state they want to be able to power the
data products that you're building today
and those could be things like business
analytics
finance marketing sales
having predictive analytics around you
know the success of their business and
making decisions off of that data that's
one use case another use case is
actually just building data products
themselves building
applications that are mobile or web or
have high volume of transactions that
are associated with those like for
example like a sports betting company
that would be an example of building a
data product
ml deep learning pipelines is another
one
using these these pipelines to
really drive and take the business to
the next step in their their ai journey
for trustworthy data so
all this at the end of the goal though
what they're really trying to do is
they're trying to deliver the data in a
trustworthy way
to eventually get to their
consumers
now this would be great if everything
works well in these these pipelines
right but i hate to break it to you but
that's not how things work
we also know that um data engineers are
spending around 50 of their time
actually maintaining these pipelines
because things break and things are
constantly
halting them for uh hosting them from
building these really cool data-driven
products in their organization today
so where does observability come in well
it all goes back to being able to
monitor and observe your data pipeline
so let's walk through and examine the
examples of this the problems these data
engineers these teams will face um with
this training analogy that i wrote up
here so the first one is this if you're
on a train
and you're sitting there waiting for it
to move the first thing you're going to
ask is is the train moving or not
you want to be able to understand right
away hey is the train moving and that
relates back to a pipeline is the
pipeline actually operational is the
pipeline executing or is it failing or
is it halted is it stalled
if the data pipeline is not moving
correctly if it's not moving at all this
data cannot get to the end consumer the
next question is like well how fast is
this train going you know is it is it
going at ninety percent eighty percent
twenty percent
did it did it take an hour when it
should have taken five minutes did it
take ten hours it should have taken one
hour this is a problem if we don't
understand
how the if we don't know exactly when
the data is going to be first
operationalized and running an
orchestration with uh with the pipelines
but also if we have a data sla that
needs to get there at a certain time
well we got to know that we got to know
that that's going to that's going to be
a problem right so that's the first part
the second part is around the cargo on
the train
so all trains hopefully they're taking
cargo maybe they've got cars maybe they
got
computers whatever it is well the next
question is okay if our pipeline is
running really good well what's going on
with the actual data sets there's
basically the cargo on that pipeline
this is what gets into understanding if
there's any things going on anything
going on with the data at the data set
level so for example there could have
been
a
schema change to this we had no idea
about so we were expecting 10 columns
when we got 11. we're expecting 10
columns and we got 9.
that's a problem because that data is
going to be impacted downstream with
something that's going to consume that
data set
we also could have sent a null record
through a let's say it was a really high
value piece of data that we expected to
come through every single day and didn't
happen that's a problem or if the data
actually changed if all these are checks
and one's in x that's a problem it's
going to corrupt the data downstream
with the data we're moving in these data
pipelines so we so the first one is
really around the process quality the
second one is around the data quality
within the actual pipeline and the next
one is around the lineage so if you are
on a train the train is going to go
somewhere
eventually it's going to drop off the
cargo it's going to go on different
tracks it may hook up
change trains may go to if you're going
from georgia to new york city maybe you
stop in delaware for an example as an
example this really gets into data
lineage which is how are things
connected to dependent pipelines
and data sets
downstream so for example if we can
if we know the pipeline is is working
good but then we find that there's a
problem in the actual data with the
pipeline the next question is how does
this this uh problem here impact
something downstream of another data set
that's consuming from another pipeline
so we want to know right away if this
fails we don't be able to know that it's
going to impact this this person down
here to let them know
and this is what data observability is
all about what we're doing is we're
operationalizing the incident detection
so whenever we see a problem at the
source the warehouse
even downstream at the at the product
level we will be able to alert up into
the data engineering team so they can
notify be notified right away when a
problem occurs they can fix it and
prevent it from getting
from impacting downstream consumers and
ultimately having big costly impacts to
the business and so
really the tenets of data observability
is to detect earlier get those get those
detections right away at the source
resolve them faster and know exactly
where they are
and how they affect other people
downstream and then ultimately deliver
that trust for the data to hit your
expected data slas for your end
consumers so
to wrap it up we talked a little bit
about the the industry of what's going
on law software engineers moving data
into data engineering they need the
tools to help them be able to
operationalize any incidents that occur
within their data pipelines we gave a
complex a simplistic example of a very
complex workflow that data engineers are
constantly dealing with which is pumping
source data all the way to their end
consumers and dealing with tons of
different tools in between
that could
prevent a bad issue or a
a dirty data problem downstream to the
consumers and we also had a little fun
talking about how this connects into a
train analogy so i really hope you
enjoyed this video about what is data
observability and check back for the
channel for more videos in the future
thanks everyone if you like this video
and want to see more like it please like
and subscribe if you have any questions
please drop them in the comments below